allez reprenons depuis le début monsieur
maccoll je vous le dis je suis pour rien
dans la santé la maladie la santé et la
menace de t'aimer de chérir et eni et de
chérir jusqu'à ce que la mort nous
sépare
jusqu'à ce que la mort nous sépare avec
cette année je t'épouse avec cet anneau
gens qui poussent et je m'engage à
t'aimer pour l'éternité et je m'engage
atb pour l'éternité
je suis morte à lise l'histoire de notre
famille ça c'est l'église où ta mère et
moi on s'est mariés ça c'est ta maison
elle est solide et pour finir en beauté
sa chambre aux mairies pitre 2 sera
jantes 18 c'est la dernière
l'antéchrist à y gagnera dites nous ce
qui s'est vraiment passé